breaking right now at four o'clock the
push for impeachment after the assault
on the capitol is moving quickly
three of nevada's representatives now
calling for impeachment
and there are reports the president's
cabinet is also looking to have him
removed from office
the i-team's david charns live in the
newsroom with new details at four david
well kirsten it's the story we first
broke here on eight newsnow.com and
inside our app it is a very short
timeline president trump only in office
now for two weeks
but constitutional experts tell us
impeaching him starting now
would bar him from ever holding office
again if it is passed now nevada
congressional democrats stephen horsford
susie lee
and dina titus all signing on to this
today all voted to impeach president
trump last year
today all three followed house speaker
nancy pelosi in saying either president
trump's cabinet needs to remove him or
congress will
now we also spoke to senator catherine
cortez masto about what happened at the
capitol she took these photos
after spending hours after in a secure
location in the capitol she tells us she
was on the senate floor when protesters
stormed into the building you're seeing
the aftermath there
and she says she's waiting to see what
the cabinet and then what the house does
before taking a stance on any next steps
i really question whether enough time to
do it and even on the 25th amendment
that is going to be something that the
vice president and the cabinet will have
to do
to move forward on and so
if they send it over i'll take the
appropriate action on both of them
of course the senate the last step on
those issues now we can confirm no one
from our area was arrested in the riot
yesterday so far but the fbi is working
to find everybody
they got four thousand tips overnight
now we also talked to assemblyman tom
roberts he is a republican representing
clark county and a former assistant
sheriff he says what he saw
he was just appalled to see it
what we saw yesterday is not indicative
of what we should tolerate
in our nation and it's it's completely
uncalled for
incoming nevada assembly woman annie
black a republican was at yesterday's
rally and told the associated press that
she
left as that group then moved on to the
cap
capitol grounds we did reach out to her
today and we have not heard back
now coming up all new at 4 30 here on
eight news now more on what invoking the
25th amendment really means
and why the president could be impeached
after he leaves office in two weeks
for now live in the newsroom i'm david
sharon 8 news now